In an old house, an old woman gathers her
knitting supplies. This is a special project,
for a little boy named Tommy she loves dearly.
She knits furiously, and soon the mix of cotton,
synthetic fiber, and cloth of every color turn
from raw materials into something else - a teddy
bear. She puts the finishing touches on the
bear - this is a very special bear, after all,
and sends the patchwork bear off to its
destination with a red get-well card.
The card is labeled “Kairos the Bear”,
and inside she writes a personal note.
“To Tommy,
Because only time can mend all wounds.
Love, Grammy”
But this package full of love
would never reach its destination.
SCP-2295 was found at the site of a crashed
mail truck, and it looks exactly like a standard
handmade teddy bear - with one difference.
On the left side of its chest, just under its
jaunty tan bow, it wears a heart shaped pin.
But not a standard cartoon heart - this is a
disturbingly realistic, anatomically correct pin
of a heart organ. And that’s because SCP-2295 has
a specific purpose - and it’s one that has
everything to do with actual human organs.
SCP-2295 spends most of its time completely inert,
spending its days as just another cuddly stuffed
toy. Tests performed on the toy revealed it had
no unusual properties and seems to be a normal
handmade keepsake - that is, until someone is
injured in its presence. Not any injury will do,
a paper cut or even a broken arm for
example won’t do much to activate its
anomalous properties. But if it detects a
critical injury to a human organ nearby,
it will trigger its secret power
- one that the Foundation is still
trying to figure out how it works.
Because SCP-2295 is a miracle worker.
When it senses the presence of someone with a
serious injury to an organ and is within two
meters of them, SCP-2295 springs into action.
Suddenly, from unknown sources, the bear will
produce objects including scissors, white thread,
and sewing needles or a crocheting hook from its
mouth. If there are any crafting supplies
on hand, it will incorporate those as well.
And then, it gets to work. Despite only having
hands made of fabric and stuffing with no
fingers, the anomalous bear is still able
to craft what will end up being a patchwork
recreation of the damaged human’s organ. Cute, if
a little creepy, but that’s just the beginning.
The injured person mysteriously falls unconscious,
and the patchwork organ, which the Foundation has
designated as an SCP-2295-1 instance, will
disappear. The SCP-2295-1 instance will then
physically replace the damaged organ inside the
person’s body. It’s unknown how this happens,
the patchwork organ will simply appear inside of
their body, taking the place of the original lung,
or kidney, or whichever organ was failing.
It’s unknown where the original organ goes to,
since it seems to just disappear as soon
as the 2295-1 instance takes its place.
Surprisingly, having this new cotton stuffed
heart of liver does not seem to cause any harm,
and in fact, it works exactly like the real thing.
There are never any of the usual issues that come
with a transplant like the risk of it being
rejected by the body, as the organic tissue
seems to have no issue connecting with the organ
and treating it like it was there all along.
In all instances of SCP-2295 performing
this adorable but rudimentary surgery,
the subjects have made a
full and complete recovery.
SCP-2295 might sound like a miracle worker,
but that isn’t to say that its abilities
aren’t without their own set of complications.
When faced with two injured subjects, SCP-2295
seems to always gravitate towards fixing the
younger subject up first - maybe owing to
its creation by a grandmother who wanted to
heal whatever was ailing her grandson. No one
knows who Tommy was or exactly what disease or
injury he was recovering from, but his grandmother
clearly felt it was serious enough to create this
special bear for him. While SCP-2295 will heal
anyone, it seems to be primarily a guardian
for the young. And it takes its duties very
seriously - even to the point of self-sacrifice.
While SCP-2295 is able to pull some
of its supplies out of thin air,
it still always needs some raw materials to craft
the new organ, including fabric and stuffing.
And if there are none available, SCP-2295 will
obtain them the hard way. The patchwork bear
will sacrifice its own body, tearing itself
open and removing any fabric or stuffing it
needs without any concern for its own well-being,
in order to craft a new organ for its patient.
It slowly regenerates its own stuffing, at
the rate of around a gram of stuffing per day,
but it needs to harvest fabric
to repair its outer layer,
which the Foundation happily makes available to
it, offering it a variety of patterns and types.
It’s no surprise that a teddy bear capable
of healing mortal wounds would be of great
interest to the SCP Foundation, and as soon
it was recovered from the crashed mail truck,
they immediately began tests to find out more
about it. Could it heal literally any organ?
Were there any limits to its abilities?
There was only one way to find out,
and the Foundation had the perfect test subjects
- D-Class Personnel, whose interactions with
non-cuddly teddy bear SCPs frequently left them
with critical external and internal injuries.
The first test subject brought in, D-2353, a
thirty-eight year old man who was in poor health
not due to his work as a D-class personnel, but
from his years and years of heavy smoking. His
lungs were seriously damaged, which gave him
trouble breathing and made any serious physical
exertion extremely difficult. He wasn’t critically
injured or in danger of dying immediately,
but that didn’t matter to SCP-2295. D-2353 quickly
passed out and the bear sprang into action.
It proceeded to take two textile swatches, one
black and one red, and create a pair of fabric
lungs which it installed in the patient.
When he awoke, D-2353 found he had full,
healthy lung function again, as if
he’d never picked up his deadly habit.
But now the Foundation researchers needed to
know how SCP-2295 would do with
even more complicated ailments.
D-3542 was fifty years old and his heart was not
in good shape. Not only did he have a serious
case of atherosclerosis, which is a disease where
cholesterol plaque builds up and blocks blood flow
and can put you at a serious risk of a heart
attack, but he also had an irregular heartbeat.
This D-Class was in bad shape, but
that was no problem for SCP-2295,
who took a collection of different colors of yarn
and a crocheting hook and created a plushy heart.
Just like the lungs had acted as if they were
completely regular organs, after the heart
anomalously ended up inside the man’s chest it
began to beat normally and performed all the
complicated functions of a human heart. But there
was one detail that shocked the onlooking doctors.
Before the yarn organ had vanished, the
doctors had seen that it was beating.
So is there any organ that SCP-2295 can’t replace?
That was about to be tested when D-7894 was
brought in. A twenty-four-year-old woman, she
had suffered serious burns all over her torso,
left abdomen, and right leg. She was brought
in and sedated to numb the agonizing pain,
and researchers were worried that they had come
up against the limit of SCP-2295’s abilities,
since the skin is the largest organ after all. But
SCP-2295 wasn’t fazed at all, the bear immediately
started sewing segments of patchwork fabric and
layering them onto the damaged skin, replacing the
dermis and epidermis layer by layer. Unlike the
other cases, these replacement organs are visible,
and D-7894 now has patchwork skin, just
like her talented surgeon. And amazingly,
the fabric has the same sense of
touch that her regular skin did.
The final test of SCP-2295’s abilities came with
D-2723, who was only eighteen years old. This last
minute D-Class test was performed because he was
showing signs of a severe cerebral hemorrhage,
the kind that would cause brain damage in only
minutes, and would be followed soon after by
complete brain death. SCP-2295 sprung to life,
but as soon as it examined the test subject,
it became distressed. It started frantically
grasping at random materials around it,
as if it didn’t know what to do with them. Then,
it reached inside itself and provided a large
chocolate bar, which it offered to the subject,
sadly to no effect. It then seemed to admit defeat
as it grabbed tightly onto the subject’s leg.
Observers reported that it was leaking a tear-like
solution from its small knitted eyes as it
embraced the dying D-Class in his final moments.
Sadly, it seems that the human brain is the
one mystery that even SCP-2295 can’t solve.
SCP-2295 appears to pose no threat to anyone
and was classified as safe after testing. It’s
inactive when not in the presence of an injured
person and has never displayed hostile instincts
when active. The Foundation determined that
it should be stored in a standard containment
locker in Site-37, where it can be kept safely
until it’s needed for tests or to repair an
injured SCP personnel. Access is limited to
those with Level 3 or higher security clearance,
and any contact with the bear is highly regulated.
But there is one element of SCP-2295’s existence
that continues to worry Foundation staff.
SCP-2295’s full origins and
the grandmother who crafted it
are unknown. The note it was found with is the
only clue as to where it may have come from,
but there are plenty within the Foundation who
are suspicious of the veracity of the letter.
And they have good reason not to be
too trusting, because another bear
with similar abilities exists - and it is
distinctly less benevolent than SCP-2295.
SCP-1048 is also a teddy bear, but it is capable
of moving on its own and communicating through
gestures at all times. It was initially allowed
to wander around independently and seemed to make
its home at Site 24 a happier place. But then
it began to display its own crafting abilities.
SCP-1048 is able to craft duplicates of itself,
and while the original was seemingly harmless,
the ones it made were not. These similarly
shaped bears were made of disturbing materials
and were extremely hostile towards any humans
they encountered. The first, SCP-1048-A,
was made entirely out of human ears and
when it shrieked, it caused anyone nearby
to generate ear-like growths all over their
bodies, eventually causing them to suffocate.
The creature disappeared - and an on-site
researcher was found to be missing an ear.
The creations of SCP-1048 only got
stranger and deadlier from there.
SCP-1048-B was found in the Site’s cafeteria,
where it was moving around in a halted,
jerky fashion. It then started bursting at
the seams and revealed what appeared to be
a human fetus inside. When the creature
screamed, it sounded like a much louder
version of a human infant and its croes caused
massive internal damage to anyone around it.
SCP-1048-B was killed in the ensuing conflict
with Foundation agents, ending its threat.
But SCP-1048 was learning deadlier techniques.
When SCP-1048-C was discovered, it looked to be a
teddy bear made entirely out of rusty scrap metal.
When it was spotted by Dr. Carver
and targeted by Foundation personnel,
the creature turned violent and proved
to have incredible strength - jumping
through the agents who were trying to
neutralize it, tearing through their bodies
like tissue paper. Attempts to damage it were
unsuccessful, and both it and the bear made
out of ears are still on the loose along with
the original SCP-1048. Capturing it is a major
priority for the Foundation - because no
one wants to see what it will create next.
Is there a connection between these
two very different teddy bears?
No one has been able to answer this question. The
origins of SCP-1048 are unknown, and so is any
connection to the mysterious grandmother who may
have made Kairos the Bear. But their abilities are
similar, with both able to craft living
objects out of seemingly any material.
They just have very different ideas as to what
a good use of their crafting abilities are.
It’s fortunate that an anomaly as potentially
powerful as SCP-2295 seems to only want to do one
thing. To help those in need, especially
those who are the most vulnerable.
For more on another apparently
harmless object with mysterious powers,
watch “SCP-066 - Eric’s Toy”, or check
out this SCP Explained video instead.